we're talking about
some of the greatest baseball players to
ever put on a baseball uniform
stars shining bright above
breezes seem to whisper i
love you birds singing
in the sycamore tree
dream a little dream of me
during the late 1800s during the time of
civil war
we knew that major league baseball was a
sport that was really building their
foundation
we just finally formed the u.s colored
troops
and when they were in camp what were
they doing for entertainment
getting the wood a rock and they were
playing baseball
here we are fighting in the civil war
and yet could not play what was
america's national pastime
during the late 1800s they didn't
actually have
black leagues what they had is like
regional teams so
there was black baseball being played
right along with everybody else
right from the beginning there was a
colored line and part of the reason it
was the colored lines because
the black teams were so outstanding that
they knew that
they would be defeated if they bought
them into the league so
they immediately banned those teams
essentially they began to play their
game
in isolation when we go back and look at
the early era of black baseball
it was pretty haphazard
[Music]
you had several folks of dark skin
who had made their way into what we now
know
as major league baseball moses fleetwood
walker was
as we kind of recognized the first known
black player to play on what would be
considered a major league team
fleetwood walker was a barehanded
catcher tony mullane
who was a white pitcher didn't want to
receive signs from moses fleetwood
walker
so fleetwood walker caught all year not
knowing when a curve ball was coming
and it didn't last very long before guys
like adrian cap anson
formed what we call quote unquote a
gentleman's agreement
that ultimately banned blacks from
playing on
white major league teams and that
agreement would stay in place for the
next six decades
in 1887 there was an attempt to form
a major league of black baseball it
didn't really have the organization
and the finances i think they played 13
games
and then they were done but the movement
was there the concept was there the idea
was there
that people would support an
organization like this
the history of colored baseball by saw
white it's very instrumental in
covering a period of baseball that we
have no way of
knowing more about because those people
from the early 1900s have long
been deceased the book was
groundbreaking in that it introduced
ballplayers that we never heard of
from his book we learned about pete hill
who's in the hall of fame
emmett bowman so many great ball players
that we
didn't know about are documented this is
the first black man who's
actually chronicling the history of
african-american baseball
baseball was truly black america's game
in that early
part of the century everyone talks about
that blacks couldn't play in the major
leagues but what folks don't recognize
is that african-american teams would
play against barnstorming teams from the
major leagues from the minor leagues so
blacks and whites played against each
other before jackie robinson integrated
baseball
if we really want to get honest about it
they knew these guys could play
but because of society in america
they couldn't find a place for them
because the racism was more important
than the national game in that book one
chapter was written by andrew roof
foster
you can't tell the story of the negro
league without starting with the man
andrew rue foster the father the father
of black baseball
whether we're talking black baseball
white baseball blue
green red yellow is the greatest
baseball
mind this sport has ever seen
ruth also played the game rude was a
dominant yet dynamic picture
he is credited with having invented what
we now know to be
the screwball it is recorded that he won
44 straight games in the season just
imagine that compared to today's he
actually got his nickname rube
from an exhibition game he went up
against hall of famer rude waddell
and he actually beat him so his
teammates started calling him rube and
that nickname stuck with him
ru foster became a manager 1907.
he became manager of the chicago leland
giants his team
was one of the greatest teams in america
rube foster became an
owner he literally went to owner frank
leland and said
i want you to give up all of your
controlling rights mr lena refused as
you would think any owner would
but rube at that point in time just said
okay then i i quit
and that's what he did he quit he took
mr leland to court
for the naming rights of the leland
giants and he ultimately won
ruth developed and created his own team
as the leland giants and that's how he
became owner of the team
[Music]
around 1919 rule foster started to
travel around and meet with
different owners of teams in the major
cities
and so they came together in the paseo
ymca
and they realized that okay we can pull
this off in the west
there were some efforts to create a
negro league but they had failed
we didn't get that real magic formula
until 1920 when ruth foster forms
the negro national league